probably spending like seven or eight
million dollars I want to give a hundred
people a hundred thousand dollars they
go you're crazy I can't keep going I
don't recommend you guys try this
[Music]
me Donaldson aka Mr Beast is by far the
most dominant YouTuber on the planet and
somehow we got him to come on the iced
coffee hour for a one hour exclusive
interview where he reveals unbelievable
details on his business that have never
been shared before this burger has done
over 100 million in sales the main
Channel now probably like three or four
million a month so if you're interested
in this and want to see more episodes
like this hey you should subscribe right
now because we have episodes coming out
every single Sunday here on the iced
coffee hour thank you so much and on to
the episode but first we have to thank
our sponsor of this episode epidemic
sound the best tool for all creators to
soundtrack their content we use it Mr
Beast uses it and so many of your
favorite creators do too epidemic is
hands down the best tool for video
creators to soundtrack and monetize
their videos without receiving copyright
strikes or worrying about takedowns
after all if you want to make the best
content you have to have the best tools
and epidemic sounds has the best music
and sound effects for your videos we
personally have been using epidemic
sound for nearly two years now if you
don't believe us go back to the second
video we ever posted on this to family
and check out the intro
and we've been using epidemic sound in
almost every video since then because
they've seriously been that good and
considering epidemic's massive library
of over 35 000 tracks and 90 000 sound
effects that's not just copyright free
but actually good it's no surprise to us
and so many other creators why it's the
go-to music tool in video creation all
tracks are professionally produced by a
diverse group of artists and exclusive
to epidemic sound meaning you can't get
them anywhere else their personal plan
is ideal for Content creators as it
covers most platforms including YouTube
Facebook Instagram twitch and podcasts
and for all of you entrepreneurs out
there they also offer a commercial plan
it's the perfect choice for businesses
Freelancers and agencies to soundtrack
their content so be sure to check them
out using the link Down Below in the
description and additionally use the
code tich 50 to receive a 30-day trial
plus 50 off your next two months when
signing up for a personal plan I really
believe you guys are going to enjoy it
and now with that said let's get back to
the podcast welcome back to iced coffee
I'm your host Mr Beast these are some
guests I brought on and I'm going to be
interviewing them to see how much money
they make how's it going guys good good
guess how much we've made
uh on this channel yes uh how many views
what is it 33 million views and what's
the average length of the video about an
hour and a half okay last question how
many minerals do you do Graham likes to
do one every like three four minutes
okay three four minutes yeah no we
change it to like whatever attendance
categorized as a finance Channel yes
education okay so 30 I would say
probably 11 RPM so three I would say 300
Grand that's so that is so cool it's
just an analytical answer we've ever
seen
252. there you go a great answer yeah
some of those views are shorts so
actually if we take out the shorts
so it is around a 10 RPM that's pretty
much exactly what it is okay yeah it's
very good now yeah because like if you
put like stock or like S P 500 you can
get like 20 or 25 but I assume not every
title is like perfect keywords so some
could be like six but your better ones
could be 12 in like the medium yeah I've
seen for Shopify and Amazon FBA it's
about 30 to 40.
insane some of the credit card videos
I've done have been about that yeah 100
yeah I I almost considered doing a
finance Channel at one point just
because of that like I gave uh whatever
like all 10 people credit cards and then
like check back six months later to see
who has higher credit score like things
like that
um but I never ended up doing it I
thought you were about to say who has
the most debt yeah which is weird things
like that like applying or format to
finance because it was like I had that
realization one day I was like I could
make like eight times the money for the
same views if I just revolved it around
Finance yeah so what excites you the
most for YouTube what excites me the
most
oh gosh just blanket YouTube yeah
um everything I mean what doesn't you
know uploading videos the the Creator
economy and just this growing YouTube's
growing everything's growing I mean
every part of it is great like the
freedom you have to to do whatever
YouTube is like name a better industry
right now like YouTube is just growing
so much and I don't think it's gonna
slow down what excites you about it the
most so not necessarily YouTube with the
process of making videos like what do
you get from it
it's gonna sound weird because I just
said this but yeah I mean like
everything like if money
make videos Fame make videos happiness
make videos of kind of like everything
in my life currently that I want to
improve kind of just revolves around
just making videos so the answer really
is kind of everything for me you know
what I mean uh I don't know if there's a
cop out it's good how do you stay
focused for me it's never really that's
never really been a thing I just it's
almost from the problem I'm having right
now is I struggle to wind down at night
because I just work and work and I'll
lay in bed and I'll think of ideas and
I'll think of just like you know well we
could have done better how we could have
edit a video better or finances or
whatever so it's actually not even the
same I'm a little too focused right now
which is something I always have to
correct myself because I usually go to
bed at like 4 a.m even though I get in
bed at like 10 p.m I'll sit there for
like six hours on average right now so
I'm trying to like actually find ways to
like pull back a little bit and so I
sleep a little bit better when is the
moment that you realize that you could
turn this into a business oh gosh that's
a good question so probably when I
started making around twenty thirty
thousand dollars a month is when it kind
of clicked in my head that um you know I
could hire someone for a couple Grand
and basically double my output because I
was doing everything right I was like
building whatever like if I wanted to
buy 5000 plates and like throw it off a
building and break them all I'd have to
order them all and I'd have to set them
up unpack them all and like building
Contraption of editing camera I was
doing it all I did that for the first
thousand videos and it kind of clicked
in my head I couldn't tell you which
video maybe it was like how many rolls
of duct tape does it take to stop a car
or whatever but I was just like wait a
minute if I just had a helper I could do
this two times faster I could upload
twice as much and if I'm doing you know
20 30 grand a month in revenue and one
person would double it and you know I
could hire first for like four or five
grand it's kind of a no-brainer and so
then I just brought on a guy to help me
move boxes and just help with the simple
stuff and I was like oh well now let me
go hire an editor and that was Game
Changer because uh although that took a
very long time like a year plus to train
because it's very hard to find someone
who understands your style and then then
I got a cameraman and then just kind of
snowball from there and then I just
basically hired someone every month for
the last like six years what's been the
most difficult part to Outsource the
most difficult part the Outsource
everything the channel is still my
Creative Vision it's like I'm the one
who spent my entire life obsessing and
building the brand and studying This and
like so
um
like even editing I still do like 10
revisions and I have a big hand in it
and the writing of the videos and like
how the videos I mean almost nothing's
like truly outsourced because like you
can't just like go here's my band here's
kind of the videos I want just give me a
video every week like if you know
because they haven't spent their entire
lives obsessing over this they don't
know as much so basically everything if
you ever had to fire anybody before of
course yeah it's never fun but you know
usually what happens is like you bring
them on for something you think you need
and it's like oh we're going this path
and we're going to do videos where we I
don't know like donate the twitch
streamers or easy runs and then next
thing you know you're doing squeegee
game level videos and those you know are
a little bit outside their skill set or
whatever because we're just changing so
much it's kind of hard to predict what
we need but I mean turnover happens
everywhere it's just kind of part of it
have you personally fired people and how
does that process go do you have someone
else doing it well now we have HR so
obviously I don't have to handle it but
yeah back in the day usually it's I like
to see it more as helping them
transition to other companies like
sometimes times you know we had one
person who we moved out here and it
didn't end up working out and so I you
know I was like what do you want to go
do is there a different YouTuber you
want to work for and I just dm'd a bunch
of other YouTubers helped him get a job
it just kind of depends sometimes they
want to go work for other YouTubers and
I help them or sometimes what was it one
guy we wanted he wanted to go work for
Tyler the Creator and so I was I was
like I tried I tried to get Tyler to
credit so I could be like hey this guy I
vouch he's pretty good
um so I like to see if more is like
helping them transition to like whatever
their next career because like there's
no hard feelings whether you're here or
somewhere else I want them to be happy
so I try to set them up for success and
just do whatever I can to you know pay
him back for what they invested in my
company that's cool how many hours do
you work in a day
depends what you classifiers work
because the answer could be every hour
I'm awake if just laying in bed thinking
about YouTube as work you know what I
mean like or if we so just about I would
say since I was 11 years old almost
every waking hour of the day I'm
thinking of YouTube in some form or
capacity basically why do you think you
have such that level of focus
because that's what I love I feel like
it was almost like baked in My DNA like
it just Flows In My Blood the the innate
urge to create videos and to build a
YouTube channel and build businesses
it's just that's just what I do and if I
like try to take time off I just get
depressed and I I feel like I lose my
sanity but I also feel like I lose my
Sandy because we've cranked the
treadmill so much on creating videos so
it's like weird but if I'm not creating
then I don't feel fulfilled I don't feel
like I'm progressing then I feel like
I'm wasting my time and like am I
allowed to swear yeah yeah I just kind
of feel like a
waste of space like a piece of [ __ ] if
I'm not like making videos you know what
I mean that's interesting I feel the
exact same way yeah not necessarily with
the making videos but if I'm not working
towards something or working on
something I feel terrible exactly like I
have low energy I just want to sleep I
don't want to do anything I feel sad but
when you're in the zone uh what do they
call it
um when you're in the zone
yeah oh it's it's uh being in the Flow
State when you're in that state where
like time seems as though it's stopped
entirely and like a day went by that's
what I love and there's something about
that that opens up like some sort of
creativity that most people don't get
until they're in that place I agree do
you know how many income sources you
have that's an interesting one well
let's see we have Beast Burger uh
feastables we have a company where we
dub channels which runs our Mr Visa
espanol and stuff like that we do that
for other people we have Mr Beast Mr
Beast gaming Beast reacts I mean would
you count Mr Beast espanol okay well
then Mr Visa espanol Mr Beast uh how
many languages are there well a lot to
summarize all the languages all the
languages which there's like 20 of those
um and then and they're starting to do
more views than my English channels
which is crazy wow yeah
um and
what else do we have going on yeah merge
as another one it's kind of hard I kind
of forget the stuff we're doing uh
honestly I'd have to like open my bank
account look through it because like
there's also like sub opportunities like
we occasionally do things for like we
built this app where uh we had people
put their finger on the outside yeah so
we're building other apps in the future
so probably somewhere around 10. what
would you say your main source of income
is if you're depicting one thing what
but see the problem is like what does
income even mean like I don't I don't
really make money I just reinvest it all
so it's like which one and also I'm
talking gross are we talking profits
because if it's gross it's Beast Burger
Beast Burger is absolutely crushing it
but it's food so the margins aren't as
good you know what I mean whereas like
feastables be um the margins are a lot
better especially because we do a lot of
sales d2c online so it's just higher
merch the best margins but you know it's
you just like a burger or whatever you
know it's something someone can order
multiple times a week merch so I'm gonna
buy like twice a year you know what I
mean what about sponsorships oh yeah and
sponsorships oh gosh yeah those have
gotten crazy recently
um well I would say so again gross or
profit or well discuss both in all yeah
so gross I guess would be peaceful I
mean yeah these I here I was I recently
tweeted so I'll say this because I tweet
you can throw it up that uh Beast Burger
has done over 100 million in sales wow
um and obviously that number's grown a
lot bigger since then so like but again
it's because it's something people can
repeatedly buy
um and then but actual money I guess
would be brand deal ad Revenue well well
if you include all the channels yeah
it's definitely ad Revenue could you
walk us through a normal day like from
wake up like what does a day look like
there's no such thing as a normal day
but I can pick some random days in the
last month
um so like or actually here's some of
our days coming up so one of our videos
coming up we're gonna spend
um a night in a one dollar hotel and
then about like a thousand dollar Hotel
ten thousand dollar fifty thousand
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
five hundred up to a million so for
example next week I'm gonna be flying to
India to stay in like a one dollar hotel
and then like at ten thousand dollar
hotel in the Maldives and then we're
going to like uh just whatever we're
gonna be traveling all over the world
I'm gonna be doing that for two weeks
and then when I get back well that means
gaming a reacts all behind so I'm gonna
have to do a whole day of catching up on
reacts videos I'm gonna have to do a day
or two catching up on our gaming videos
and I've been gone so now I gotta spend
a whole day catching up on the creative
and all our other main Channel videos
and then the video after that we're
gonna do like the world's largest
experiments like we're trying to make
the world's largest balloon world's
largest paper airplane so then go work
on that and I'm probably gonna go film a
couple of those and then come back and
you know and then you Beast burger and
feastables are probably gonna wet my
head on a platter because I just spent
two weeks traveling filming that video
and I haven't been talking to them as
much so then probably those meetings
will probably fly into town and then we
have other companies so it's kind of
ebb's inflow the main channel is the
priority and then around the main
Channel schedule the rest of my life
kind of like forms with all the other
businesses but Jimmy you know what
before we go into that we gotta thank
our sponsor ftxus for those unaware
they're one of the largest US regulated
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
with millions of users who buy sell
track and trade both crypto and nfts all
in one place with fees that are up to 85
lower than top competitors seriously
guys they've been sponsoring this
podcast for a super long time and they
help us do what we do for you guys every
single Sunday so it would mean a lot if
you guys checked him out with that link
Down Below in the description it not
only supports us but also helps you guys
out because they are an amazing exchange
we couldn't recommend them anymore and
plus they're giving you all the way up
to a hundred dollars with the free
crypto depending on how much you trade
when you use the link Down Below in the
description along with free crypto and
every single trade you make over ten
dollars plus buying crypto is super easy
all you have to do is Select what you
want to buy how much of it you want to
buy how often you want to buy it and
then swipe right and you're done without
any additional work on your end and they
also allow you to do automatic recurring
Buys so you guys can invest exactly how
we do and that's on a recurring basis
another really cool thing is they're
soon launching FTX stocks where you're
going to be able to trade stocks crypto
and nfts all in one platform with super
low fees trust me guys you're going to
want to check it out so hope support the
podcast and also trade on an exchange
that charges you very low fees with the
link Down Below in the description it
means a lot thank you guys so much and
back to the podcast do you have any sort
of daily routine now like every morning
I mean like I'm gonna be gone for two
weeks and then when I get back I'm like
I'm doing the experiments and we're you
know then I gotta play makeup on all the
other companies and then after that I
got to go to the I can't say where
because I might spoil if I can go
somewhere else for a video and then it's
just different and then next thing you
know I'm burying myself alive for 100
hours or whatever and that throws off it
and you know sometimes I sleep here
sometimes if I'm on the other side of
the Town working at the other Studio I
sleep in that studio it's like kind of
hard you know what I mean yeah who keeps
track of your schedule uh steel you
Meadow yeah yeah so I basically I tell
every whenever I want to do something
I'm like hey I need to meet with
so-and-so tomorrow I need to do this he
compiles it and then every day just
makes a prior list and then he just we
like to call it like uh block calling
like if I have calls like so today if I
have like six calls instead of doing a
call at one I call it three I call it
like five or call it eight I like to
just do them back to back to back so
like like do a call at one and then have
the other four on standby and the second
I finish I want to jump on the next one
at like 1 15 and then I jump on the next
one 135. and so then it's much easier if
the calls are stacked like that instead
of like oh I gotta call in 10 minutes
and then waiting for the call and that
kind of stuff so I don't even know where
I'm going with it but I basically wake
up and he has I dump all my stuff I need
to do and then he just kind of schedules
and prys it on whatever is most
important for the business and then I
just wake up and do what he tells me how
far ahead are you planned on that
uh let's see
uh I mean my calendar is out till the
end of the year
um but what are you doing three weeks
from today
we're going to be making the world's
largest Burger
that's crazy of it planned out like that
yeah I know everything every video we're
filming on the main Channel between now
and the year we have because they're big
projects so if we're gonna film a video
in December we got to start working on
it now so we're very far ahead where
would you say you spend most of your
time is it filming planning scripting
that's the problem man and that's why I
wouldn't recommend someone do what I do
because it's stressful it just depends
and you know if we do a gaming video
where I survive 100 days of Minecraft
that's what is that like 30 hours in
real time so because like a Minecraft
day is 20 minutes so like I could spend
30 hours to play Minecraft and then you
know the next week I'm building the
world's largest Firework and I have to
spend a week on that and the next you
know I gotta go Network or go to a
conference it's it is so sporadic and
random I couldn't tell you yeah but I
guess for the most part it's filming
main Channel videos but those are just
they're different everyone's different
I'm either in a submarine or Clowney
Mount Everest or uh putting 100 people
in a circle and see who leads last I've
been so curious could you walk us
through the process of creating a video
from start to finish how do you think of
ideas where does that start so
um I work very well off of inspiration
so I used to just like flip through a
dictionary I've told these stories
before random word generates blah blah
recently I hired a bunch of people to
just come up with interesting things or
find things to inspire me like let's say
um in Japan there's this like yellow
fruit that if you ate it just like made
You Jump 10 feet taller right you don't
know that exists let's say it does exist
but you don't know so you couldn't come
up with a video idea around eating that
fruit because you don't know it's a
thing and so I think a big part of
coming up with ideas which again this I
could give you the five hour explanation
of how to do it we do our videos or like
the shorter ones so I'm giving you the
mile high but for starters I need as
much and I need to I call it like an
information diet might be a little
cringe to call that but like my well of
knowledge needs to constantly be
expanding so I have more things to draw
inspiration from from our ideas if not
you're going to get the same ideas over
and over again so it happens for a lot
of creators that's why their videos are
repetitive and always the same thing
because if you're not constantly
learning new things then your ideas are
just limited to what's in your head and
eventually you're going to drain it
that's how I've seen it it's not so
linear point is I need to always be in
taking things so I have a team of people
who are just helping just dump and beat
new things in my head so I can get
inspired we do that we come up with a
good idea and then from there we um oh
gosh well then now we gotta write the
video so I'll usually work with Tyler
yeah and yeah have you found a process
for scripting that you think like this
format works the problem is our videos
aren't scripted and B every video is
different so like
um so we'll do the hotel one problem
with Hotel one you can't really like
plan what you're going to do or plan
shots because you don't know what the
hotels are so then you know you kind of
have to go then basically scrape every
hotel in the world above a certain price
point so like we need we know we want to
do one dollar versus a million so you
know well one dollar hotel is very hard
to find so we it's not like there's a
website you can't just Google it so we
had to like basically search all these
hotels and like you know airbnbs and
house there's like shared houses where
you could get it done which is how we
got it and then you got to find every
100 hotel and find the coolest one in
the world and then all the ten thousand
dollar ones and now you have them all
and then now you can go look at it
creatively in camera wise and then
you're like oh these aren't cool enough
these aren't cool enough and it's like a
lot of back and forth and then you know
you kind of plan it out if that makes
any sense and then oh well we need to
film this two-week window but five of
these aren't available now you got to go
back to the drawing board and find all
new ones and then you know map out a
path so you can fly around the world and
it doesn't take like a month you know
what I mean stuff like that and then
what about the filming process going to
editing yes well that's where it gets
crazy because so you're using three
cameras here well I'll use boys versus
girls for example I think we use we put
100 boys in a circle 100 girls in a
circle I think we use 60 cameras on that
video which was wild so we had 60
cameras running for 100 hours because it
was 100 hour challenge because we had to
have cameras monitoring the red lines
every inch of it or if someone stepped
out we couldn't show it like 10 wides
and then all the free roaming ones and
so
we have a dit who kind of like labels
them all like this camera and then we
take notes while we're filming so I see
something funny I'll be like hey this
time because you can only get the time
code like this happened and this
happened like during this time lapse
um like one time we had like someone
standing in the trash can and then it
fell over and they touched the line and
got out well because we have so many
cameras and so much time lapse and the
editor can't watch every footage every
minute of footage you have to like write
that down so they can like go look at
the time lapse find that and put it in
or it'll just get lost in the abyss you
know what I mean yeah how many hours
would you say it takes to edit the
average video
um hours so our 100 million subscribers
special I think we were just doing the
math I think it was like collectively
like 1700 hours across all the editors
but that was that was a really really
big video yeah but yeah because we had
to pull in a lot of Firepower for that
video we used a lot of cameras and I was
very particular on how I wanted it so we
did so many revisions like they were the
thing is like I'm I'm not the easiest to
work with in that regard like I really
want to make the video as good as
possible and so sometimes you know we'll
edit a video a certain way and then you
know
um we'll just be like well what if we
tried this and so we'll have to like
basically re-edit the video to see if
this other way produces a better story
and if it flows better and then we'll be
like oh that that's not as good and then
you go back to this one and then we try
this it's a lot of testing so we usually
edit a video like you know five or seven
times how many eyeballs look at that
video before you get to see it because
I'd imagine they show you a version it's
close maybe to what's going to post
close to done yeah and then I see it and
it's not close to done okay yeah so it's
usually
um just whichever person's editing it
and then Mario
um the guy our retention guy who just
this is kind of the obvious stuff
because like there are a lot of the
thing is I've you know we've done tons
of videos especially across all the
channels like thousands of videos at
this point they're just a lot of things
like I just don't want to have to keep
repeating myself with like certain like
obviously you know this wasn't fast
enough or this didn't flow well or like
kind of the obvious stuff when I give
notes I want to and work on the edit I
want to actually do high level things
and not be like oh just the color here
was offered obvious things like that
it's just kind of a waste of time yeah
you know what I mean how many hours go
into a title thumbnail
that's something that for me I could
sometimes spend days on a title and
thumbnail well once we pick it not as
many
um but it's all in the front end like
picking the idea is like brutal and I
mean I can tell you hundreds probably
um and then here let me show you this so
every thumbnail we do we actually do
like seven versions of it's like this is
for boys versus girls or 100 boys versus
100 girls this is like our upcoming
video like two different ones
uh this is for the 100 million
subscriber video uh
so the thumbnail we ended up going with
was A1 yeah these were our backup
options wow now A2 is that just a
storyboard to kind of give the idea
because that doesn't look like it would
be the final thing right yeah these are
all storyboards oh wow like this was a
storyboard for the final product yeah I
mean and if we went with the house
because there was a house on the island
we would have just like gotten their
shot source and recreated it and then we
had an idea of me like being in a boat
driving away from the island as the
thumbnail yeah this might sound silly do
you take the same picture and reuse it
or do you take a new thumbnail every
time of my face yeah well we have
probably a thousand different photos of
my face yeah the interesting thing is I
recently cut my hair very short yeah um
in a video because I failed a challenge
and then we went to make a thumbnail the
next video and it just didn't look like
me like because a lot of people just
recognized me for having bangs so even
though I have short hair my thumbnails
still have me with long hair because
more people recognize it
um and I thought that was funny I think
that's cool I do you ever take days off
yeah of course the thing is so the way I
like to work and I don't recommend you
guys try this uh it's
so schedules don't really work well for
me I like I'm in the zone and I like to
go hard I'm very obsessive I don't I
like to just give in to my net a lot of
people will work five days a week and
they won't work weekends and ambitious
people try to like restrain themselves
and be like you know there's a schedule
can't work Saturday can't work Sunday I
uh that just never works for me I always
end up caving so I found giving into my
natural instinct works best so I just
work every day every hour of the day
until I just burn out so like I work all
day Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday and I'll keep
going and then usually around day 10
I'll wake up and I'm just like burnt I'm
like I can't keep going it's too much
like I can't keep doing these like 12 15
hours a days and then I'll take like
half a day or maybe a day depending on
how severe it is I'll just chill and
I'll just kind of like Nuke my calendar
and then by the next day I'm fired up
and I'm ready to go and then I just do
it again and so it's weird but that's
what works really really well for me
anytime I try to stick to a schedule it
just doesn't work because there are
certain Saturdays I'm just fired up and
like like God himself couldn't stop me
from going and working on a video and
then there are other Saturdays the way
I'm burnt out and so yeah I just I just
kind of give in to my emotions and just
work when I want to which is usually
like seven to ten days in a row and then
just like take a little break till I'm
ready which is usually like half a day
or a day that's really cool how many
people work for you
loaded question
um
do we count the people working in the
Pittsburgh restaurants or no no okay I
would suggest here because it seems like
I met a lot of people from your team
yeah and that number is a little closer
involved it's getting big
um it's definitely getting big I I'd say
in general right between feastables and
all the stuff we're doing
like full-time salary probably a 150
people maybe maybe 200 just kind of
depends so a lot of like part-time jobs
and second-hand jobs that are spot off
and that's where it gets into like the
hundreds but yeah would you be able to
draw a flow chart for us in terms of you
at the top controlling everything who's
underneath you who's underneath them the
only problem is if I did that there are
tons of people that just copy everything
I'm doing on YouTube currently like I
breathe and like 30 other channels try
to do it and I don't want uh and I say
this about ideas don't copy me but they
do it anyways if I did that all these
YouTubers would start trying to clone it
and then they're just going to become
mini means and it's like a lot of people
for some reason have stopped taking
inspiration and doing their own twists
and they just literally flat out copy
what I do
um and so that's why I'm like say when I
you know when you ask about people or
stuff like that try not to say too much
because I know hundreds of creators are
just gonna be like that's it that's what
I'm doing I need 50 people I would have
built it like this and then I'm gonna do
what Mr Beast does you know yeah but you
would employ a lot of people that way if
all of a sudden the unemployment rate
goes to like one percent because
everyone's hiring yeah true but the big
thing is you need a production
Department to make the ideas happen you
need creative people to think on it
obviously camera and editing is you know
those are your your big four how do you
think the money is best spent for the
channel in terms of growth yes
okay
how do I think it's best spent just
making the best YouTube videos possible
I mean if we want to sell more feasibles
bars or merge or get better brand deals
it all literally just stems around you
know people watching the videos which is
does that go back then to more idea
creation or do you think it's higher
retention so better Specialists or or I
guess more advanced yeah okay it's it's
more like those things help but they're
it's not like at the end of the day like
it's like you know we put 100 girls in a
circle versus 100 boys half a million
dollar cash prize build these crazy sets
all the effort that's a big part of why
it does well right sure we can tweak a
little bit here and there and and remove
a p joke so it's a little bit more
watchable and and do this little thing
but at the end of the day it's like
that's not why people are coming back
and that's not what makes it great
that's just a little icing on top you
know what I mean yeah so like the money
is best spent and like just doing
grander things that I find interesting
that are unique original and like people
just how I would put it can't find
anywhere else so you can't find what we
do for the most part some videos here
and there but for the most part you
can't find what we do anywhere else not
at the scale we do and I think it's like
that is where I want to put the money in
because then that's what gets people
coming back they enjoy it and then
everything else benefits do you know how
much it costs in terms of running your
overall business every month just like a
ballpark oh gosh yes
so what it's just a Mr Beast Channel
gaming reaction everything under the
umbrella oh gosh oh I mean
could be a round number I mean yeah
because like even like so like feasibles
is about to go into retail and like even
just that like we just filled like a
four million dollar purchase order so we
can buy enough bars to fill retail do
you want me to slap that on there and
just slap it on I mean bro who's calling
me this is like the intense moment air
max volume bro hey we're talking YouTube
money go away
all right yo not right now man how's it
going we're filming it's Graham it's
Graham
what's up man
what's the question
the answer is we're playing soccer right
after this interview more importantly
yeah
how much money do you make a year is
making in the video
would you say how much money do you make
a year
oh
uh multiple Millions
oh my gosh wow
what a what a rich snobby guy wow I'm so
abundantly grateful for all of my fans
it's to build the world's most Eric
exposed he's a millionaire he just wants
to use it to make his pizza uh
a lot
okay well I would say it but now if I
sit on the back and it sound like I'm
trying to be a dick
um okay
[Laughter]
so something like that four said I made
54 Million last year
uh okay I gotta go later all right bye
gosh she's calling you the most crucial
part so how much do we spend a year so
or in a month yeah or sorry in a month
so the main Channel
uh let me see the main channel is
probably
like on the gaming channel we probably
are spending like I don't know depends
like a couple hundred thousand a month
reacts a couple hundred thousand a month
the main Channel now probably like three
or four million a month
um like feastables is spending probably
a million or so a month Beast Burger
same thing I mean if you're including
like marketing and stuff a couple
million a month
um and then yeah I mean we're probably
spending like I haven't even done this
math in a while but
Frick like it's probably seven or eight
million dollars I mean even like our
Beast uh philanthropy our charity you
know I put a lot of money into that so
we can have food and stuff like that so
yeah it's it's getting pretty crazy who
manages that
um well if you go over there up those
stairs you'll see a little accounting
team that I walk in and I go I want to
give 100 people a hundred thousand
dollars they go you're crazy and I'm
like good luck do they make sure that
money is like put aside just for you
like just in case something happened no
what what but the thing is we have a
hundred million subscribers yeah all
right what people have been saying that
since I had a million subscribers and I
always just hurry and like what's the I
don't want to say what's the worst that
happened I guess I can't buy a car but I
mean the videos give views even if I
don't upload so like if I really wanted
to I could just stop spending and just
live off the money the views make you
know what I mean are you investing any
of your own money separate from
everything else like do you take any of
it for yourself put it off to the side
I'd reinvest everything I want to just
literally all I want to do is make the
best food as possible that's why I live
in the studio right over there so I
don't like I'm not worried about paying
for a mansion I don't drive a
Lamborghini
um I'd purposely have a really like
dumbed down lifestyle so when because it
gives you Freedom like you know most
people can't reinvest in a business
because when they get to this level
they're worried about their 10 million
dollar mansion they're like four or five
cars and insurance and keeping up with
that and then like their second home and
all these other things I just cut it all
out I have no like personal debt or like
things you know that I have to pay for
so I can just go all in on the business
because it's like it doesn't even matter
you know what I mean can you talk about
maybe investing in nfts or crypto if you
want to talk about that no I mean
literally all I do is I invest in my
videos right now so I actually don't
even do any investing on the side
um back in the day you know I bought a
little bit of Bitcoin
um and did pretty good but then I ended
up just dumping it back into the videos
so do you have a credit card you would
have to ask the team over there I uh I
know I mentioned opening up my bank
account earlier but I don't even know to
log into it I don't I don't know it I
just know I see the YouTube chat come in
and then at the end of the month they
just go here's how much money you have
you're poor and they're like stop
spending so much and I go okay okay so
if we looked at your personal bank
account would your bee just like a few
hundred bucks in there no no it's not
that bad the thing is you know it's it's
my YouTube channel if I want to I can
just pull money out so if you know if I
needed let's say we we went to Vegas
like Ludwig invites me to a poker game
like obviously in the buy-in I think was
like 50 Grand like obviously I'm just
gonna pull 50 grand out and go play in
it so it's not like I don't don't have
access to Capital if I need it you know
what I mean I just you know like in the
last probably 20 days I've only left
this studio once I just live here like I
don't I don't really need money for
other things you know come on these are
the more interesting questions that I'm
personally interested in
how do you plan to expand the business
oh that's where it gets fun
oh boy well I think for starters you
know I just want to keep making the best
videos possible I have to reiterate I'm
going to sound like a broken record but
everything I do stems from that because
if I stop making the best videos people
stop watching and then festivals is
irrelevant Feast Burger is irrelevant
all the companies are just literally
irrelevant so that and then stimming off
from that next I really want to get into
uh making mobile games I think that'd be
a lot of fun because we have a gaming
channel that gets like 20 million views
of video we did the finger on the app
challenge we had two million concurrent
players and I didn't even mention it in
a video that was just like on Twitter
and Instagram I think Jack tried it yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah but so that was kind of a case
study like I can get millions of people
to play a game so I want to build mobile
games I think that would be a lot of fun
um and then I really want to scale up
feastables launch new products we're
going to launch cookies and then next I
want to do like uh I don't want to say
what's after that but it's a it'll be a
great product and then Beast Burger
we're getting into building physical
locations so in two weeks we open our
first physical piece Burger we have 2000
virtual we're building that and then
based on how that goes I want to build
10 and then 50 and then 100 physical
locations
um and just you know keep leveraging the
brand do you think there could be a
work-life balance yes sir there well not
if you want to grow as quick as we are
no I mean because at the end of the day
if I stop filming on the main channel
the video stopped going up if I stopped
filming on reacts videos stop going up
peace plans with me they stop going up
Tick Tock they stop going up main you
know what I mean so all that centers
around me and then all the side
businesses sent around me but yeah if I
wanted to I could just not build a snack
brand I could just not do a restaurant
and I could just not do normal game
company that I could just not do gaming
a gaming channel and a reacts Channel I
can just do my main Channel I'd probably
be probably way happier and have way
more free time
um but that's just not who I am and it
sounds weird but it's just ingrained in
me this those are the things that like
get me up and get me out of bed and like
when I don't do them I'm depressed so I
like pushing myself and I see it as a
sport like going hard in business and
building them
um even though it's stressful and it's
very difficult and like sometimes I'm
like you know you have a mental
breakdown you're like why am I doing
this why do I push myself so hard but
then when you're not doing it you're
just depressed so it's like a weird
system a weird situation but I love it
but sometimes I don't and here I am do
you ever get anxious randomly or just
worried about all the time yeah because
you're just like oh should I be working
on this business is this the best use of
my time should I be doing this blah blah
this blah blah 100 yeah how do you deal
with that
I just I just do I just can't keep on
working
for someone that's not a 24 year old
idiot that's only done built businesses
his entire life with no social skills do
you think eventually you want a family
and kids and or do you think interesting
question family and kids so here's the
thing Elon has kids Steve Jobs nine of
them yes he does Steve Jobs's kids Bill
Gates his kids all these Ultra
successful people not that I want to be
them or whatever but in general I just
like view building business as a video
game and you know it's kind of fun and
so all these really successful people
have kids so I used to in the past be
like heck no they're a waste of time but
then you see all these people who you
know times worth more money than anyone
else in the world an hour of their time
but they justify it and you know they
say even the most obsessed people you
can find still say it's you know having
kids brings them the most joy in their
life so
um yeah it's just like the thought of of
devoting that much time to someone for
at least 18 years is like so scary and
it's like opportunity cost size not
optimal but all these other successful
people do it and they don't regret it
like I can't really find anyone who
really has so I don't know I'm kind of
like in the that weird area where I'm
still trying to figure out like would it
make me fulfilled and would that be the
one thing where I could be where you
know it takes me away from the business
like if I raising someone and investing
my life in a mini version of me and
programming its brain to be a little
genius is that something I would enjoy
enough where I would wouldn't mind
basically setting aside 18 years of my
life from the business you know what do
you worry about is there anything that
goes through your mind where no I'm not
really a that kind of person anything
that's out of your control it's kind of
a waste of your time to worry about you
know what I mean so it was in your
control fix it if not make a mental note
and move on
this is an interesting one what's your
biggest insecurity biggest insecurity
well right now you know we're putting
all these monies into these videos and
um I I would say like storytelling I
love story time but like our videos are
very fast-paced and so sometimes you do
have to give up a little bit of the
story in order to keep the videos moving
and I was I was I feel like I've a
pretty good Storyteller but I've always
taken pride in that but especially more
recently like a lot of people say like
oh the videos are too quick or this
review is just isn't a great Storyteller
he's just good at making things move
fast and spending money and uh you know
that's not what you I ignore it so it
doesn't matter but I guess if of
anything it would be that like a lot of
people think the only reason we get
views is because I just throw money at
it and they don't realize that you know
we spent a decade just studying what
does well
um you know studying figuring out our
own style figuring out our own way to do
things and that amount of hours I put
into like just expanding the inspiration
of my brain just so I can come up with
original ideas and like the months on
months we've spent building the sets and
working on it and the weeks we spend
editing and all this and then you know
they're just like oh that he just spent
money that's it that's there's nothing
special you know what I mean is there
anything that you think that I didn't
ask that you think the audience would
want to hear or that you want to share
because this is more Finance business
oriented of course and so it's a
different audience that I feel like
could you could share something that
maybe they're not
that they didn't think of or that you
feel like more people should know
YouTube I've said this before but maybe
because your audience might not have
listened to me before I think YouTube is
only going to grow bigger and bigger
because it comes pre-installed on
Android you know Google funnels people
to it alphabet owns all this so almost
every area of the internet points to
YouTube so I think YouTube is going to
keep growing and at least like the next
five to ten years I think it's gonna
like in 10 years YouTube's going to be
bigger than television ever was for
culture in America at least in my
opinion and so I think a lot of people
underestimate that and people I don't
think people really understand just how
like to be a one of the top creators on
the biggest social media platform that
and that will also be the biggest in 10
years during that whole time like the
amount of value and how crazy that is
like you don't need a network you don't
need
um you know to go through people you
just are you can and you can do whatever
you want and you can influence people
how you want it's just wild it's
mind-blowing and you can leverage that
to build businesses or you know like do
things like Beast philanthropy or
whatever I think like people don't
realize just how crazy it is that you
have
I don't even know where I'm going with
it but like you know how much influence
the top YouTube channels have like for
us we have a hundred million people on
average that watch almost everything we
put up you know if you include
non-english in English everything we do
100 million people will watch
when when has someone else ever had that
kind of power without having to go
through a network or anything I just
upload whatever I want I can upload a
black screen you know what I mean yeah
and hit tens of millions of people it's
crazy does that ever worry you that you
have that much influence on so many
people
um no I think we're you know we we did
team trees we do tmc's typically our
stuff centers around doing good and
um no actually it excites me because uh
especially like on our peaceful entropy
Channel where so we started a food
pantry a charity 501c and we we make
videos around it and we use the money
from those videos to fund the charity
and I cover all the costs of the video
so it's 100 profit that goes into the
charity which is a non-profit uh which
is a huge cash thing but that channel
alone like I've had hundreds of parents
probably even a thousand at this point
that I mean in a Walmart or I meet out
or whatever just tell me stories of like
their kids watch that and then when they
get tooth fairy money they want to go
donated to charity or like their little
12 year old kid wants to go volunteer
because they watch the peace Plan Three
video
um Etc and I see thousands of tweets
maybe not thousands hundreds of tweets
like that a day and so no I feel like
we're doing a good job and inspiring
people to to care and you know
um yeah maybe it could be perfect but in
general I feel like compared to other
stuff we're doing a pretty good job who
do you look up to the most who'd I look
up to the most I mean I think Elon
musk's Steve Jobs Bill Gates yeah the
thing is you got to do a caveat with
them because Steve you know uh as
inspiring as he is was a little bit of a
[ __ ] yeah and so I think this is the
thing that I don't think everyone
understands you can look up to someone
without idolizing everything they do
there's never been a perfect human on
this Earth anyway I don't care you could
pick anyone you look up to someone could
find something wrong and be like Graham
why do you look up to them one time they
lied you know what I mean anyway it
doesn't matter who they are so I I do
look up to Steve but I actually think
like if he was nicer I think he would
have been more successful to be honest
like I know I don't think him being mean
to his employees and so ruthless is why
he was so successful so that out the way
yes it's definitely Steve Jobs
um he's just unrelenting passion with
making the best product ever this is the
number one product in the history of
mankind there's never been a higher
grossing product ever that's created by
someone the iPhone yeah billions right
have been sold it's wild
um and so yeah yeah it's just his
unrelenting focus on an obsession of
making the best product possible not
conceding quality I love that he also
left Apple became a billionaire Pixar
and you know was just such a creative
genius so he could make help obviously
he didn't do it all but help make Toy
Story and all those other films and
that's actually how he became a
billionaire and then Apple had to buy
next just to bring him back and you
literally can see it right when he comes
back it takes off obviously he had the
secret sauce and he knew what he was
doing and the fact that when he came
back he cut all the products so
inspiring just a laser-like focus and
obsession is just kind of what I aim to
like Implement in our videos because
it's yeah it's just
beautiful to see how do I get people to
subscribe who are watching this right
now how do I convince them well the
easiest thing is just to tell them right
if you upload a video let's say that
gets a million views and you don't say
to subscribe you might on average get a
couple thousand but if you go hey you
should subscribe right now that you know
a lot of people who wouldn't have done
it because they just didn't think of it
are now thinking about it and it will
convert to like 10 or 20 000. so
literally just say it and you're good
Jack I think has a few things he wants
to ask you okay so you always say you
want to make the best video possible but
by best what exactly do you mean do you
mean strictly just views no it's
literally just whatever makes the
audience happiest that you could
interchange it whatever makes the viewer
happy when you click on a video I want
to give you whatever emotion we're
trying to convey if it's like helping
people and we're trying to make you be
like oh or like to intensity when I'm
running from the FBI whatever that is I
just want to make it as good of a
viewing experience as possible now
question for you what if you could reach
500 million people that see that video
that are moderately happy or you get 50
million people who are really happy who
watch that video oh gosh I've never had
someone ask me that before reach a
smaller dedicated 500 not I mean the
thing is if you're reaching 500 million
people naturally there's going to be a
10 subsection of it that is really happy
so I would just pick the 500 million so
the larger number assuming that of the
larger number is smaller of course
because you don't get the larger numbers
without building dedicated fan base but
yeah no matter what like if you get a
million views of video not all million
are hardcore fans but there are going to
be hardcore fans as a subsection and the
bigger the gross number assuming the
content doesn't suck the bigger the
dedicated would you ever do a vlog just
behind the scenes I kind of did when I
didn't eat for uh 30 days yeah yeah that
was kind of it obviously I cut out a lot
of my life but yeah I've noticed by the
way I think that was the only video that
didn't go on trending
um
I didn't even notice but you're right it
did I check every single one of your
videos because I notice always within
six to 12 hours it's number one on
trending interesting when you posted
that video I was like oh crap how is
YouTube gonna respond to that do you
know how much number one Trend oh gosh
well YouTube do you know how much number
one trending per day how many uh wait
how many in terms of a person so like if
you get number one trending on YouTube
and it sits there for like half a day
how many views do you think you'll get
um I was number two once and I noticed
the view Changed by about 10 okay it
wasn't much but I can tell you because I
mean we've had hundreds of videos like
what the median view is yeah it's around
a million views
is that's the change yeah that's just
what you'll get from when you go on
trending to when you fall off if you get
up to number one it's like a million
views but for you I mean that would be
it's not a one and a half percent two
percent uh yeah but the thing is that's
great is and this is why I do like it
please keep giving me it or whoever
um uh is it's a lot of new viewers so
it's not your typical people who've seen
it so what you'll see is they come in
they watch a video and then you can
search their username like at two hours
later so they'll be like oh I've never
seen your channel before I just found it
on trending and then like two three
hours later searched her name again and
they'll be like I just watched 20 videos
I didn't know this existed like how
would you give away this what is the
show this is crazy and so that's what
that's why I like things like like even
your audience like doing this not that
this is why I'm doing it you're just a
cool guy and it's fun to hang out with
you but like you'll bring people over
and a viewer from you is like better
than like 10 of my viewers coming back
because your guy hasn't seen her channel
before so he might go watch a hundred
videos whereas the 10 coming back might
only watch one or two because they've
seen the rest does that make sense I
love that video by the way but when I
saw it I was so worried that YouTube
wouldn't want to recommend it yeah
because they would be worried about
people imitating that and be like well
I'm not going to eat now for 31. we have
tons of disclaimers and we had a doctor
throughout it yeah so yeah I don't know
I mean honestly the retention on it
wasn't as good as normal so the video is
not doing as well but I think I just
didn't I had never done a long Vlog like
that and the problem is after like day
nine I just stopped filming as much
because I was so hungry and I just was
so tired that like day nine to like 14
there was no footage and like even like
day six I just didn't record it I was
just like good morning and I was like
all I had so uh that if I could do it
over again I would have just vlogged
better and I think I could have made the
video vlogging is really difficult we
wanted to Vlog some of the trip and we
vlogged the first night like really well
and just forget yeah there's other stuff
that goes on yeah but I don't want to
film in the moment like when you're in
there you don't want to be oh wait
exactly take it your phone it just it
ruins it so I get that but I think if
you were to do some sort of personal
Vlog just from your own standpoint with
no one else around is you holding a
camera yep people would love that and
get to know you I 100 agreed my only
problem is to not show the behind the
scenes of this operation a lot and I
think we talked about this on the main
Channel video we did for you is people
just copy everything I do and I'm like I
don't I'm trying like I'm trying to like
tell these other people who like people
call Mr B's clones like take inspiration
but don't just copy and people with two
a t just do what I do every day and
there'd just be like 30 of me running
around little knees that just don't put
as much time in or money in because they
just think Fast Cuts is all we do and
you know do you ever worry about I
watched a video it's called the Mr
beastification of YouTube did you see
this video yeah actually I reached out
to him and talked to him yeah he was
really cool it was so entertaining it
was a 40 minute long video and I love
this guy's analytics of how he broke it
down do you ever worry that that it's
going to get too saturated now I know
you could always one up man you could
always make the videos better but do you
worry that that style is is I don't say
outplayed but too many people are doing
it it's becoming too common and now you
have to change to adapt the only thing
is no one's doing it at our scale with
our creativity our originality our
effort like most of these people they
literally think the only think that
makes my videos good as I just cut them
quick and they just like cut cut cut and
they think that's that's why we get 100
million views of video they don't you
know they don't they don't spend months
you know thinking of ideas and like I
talked about before like you know
studying new things so you can get
better inspiration so you can come up
with more original ideas and then you
know sometimes we work on videos for six
to eight months and all that time and
effort we put into it and our average
video is around 1.2 million dollars
right now and so the money and then we
usually sometimes like the hotel video
we're gonna be filming for two weeks
straight so all that production time all
that money all that effort all the time
on the front end with originality and
then we spend weeks editing it across
you know seven to ten revisions like
that's why the videos do well not
because we just go cut and I just throw
money you know what I mean
um and so no because ever the Mr
beastrification uh which by the way I
love the video and he was actually
really nice I reached out to him he's
he's a really great guy but um no none
of them do it right like they usually
copy like one or two aspects but we're
still the only place where you can get
the full picture you know what I mean
yeah so do you think that the current
style of content that you're producing
right now is going to be able to last
forever like the massive spectacle type
content because YouTube kind of goes
through the ebb and flow of like maybe
this style of content is performing well
now this style do you think that the
current style is going to last a long
time no I don't think like just uh what
we're currently doing is gonna be
relevant forever but that's the beauty
because we just adapt and innovate I'm
not hard set on anything I just love
creating you know and so like I used to
do these videos where I donate to Twitch
streamers like I would just go open up
their random twitch streams I'd donate
10 grand and say nothing and then just
watch them freak out people loved it we
did like 12 of those they all went super
viral very like they were getting tons
of views people were begging for more
but you know I was like 12 is enough
there's plenty that's like two hours of
content like you don't really need that
anymore and so I pivoted and I stopped
doing them even though people wanted
them and then I started doing last
sleeps people love that they're like oh
never mind forget the twitch stuff this
is cool and we did a bunch of those and
now I occasionally do them when I come
up with a really big idea and you know
and then we the thing is like you the
getting hunted by FBI did you see that
one in the Bounty Hunter and stuff and
then I pivoted into that you just always
pivot and change it up I'm not hard set
on anything the content I'll be making
in five years is different than the
content I'm making now and the content
I'm making now is different the content
I made a year ago and a year ago and a
year ago and it's always going to change
I think that's how you stay relevant you
know what I mean yeah I think Ryan
Trahan really threw a curveball with
YouTube and his 30-day penny series I
started watching I think around day 12.
yeah never watched it before in my life
but starting day 12 I watched every
single video I couldn't tell you what
was so special about it but just seeing
his first hand experience and him
spending no money I think I appreciated
that that like anybody could do this if
they really 100 100
there so two things of that there are
tons of viral ideas that people can do
that don't require money it does not
require money to go viral like at one
point one of my most few videos was like
spending
um 24 hours in a desert we just grabbed
a tent some stuff and we went to the
desert and it got like 60 70 million
views I have so many videos where we've
spent hardly any money like the no food
one on or I'd have to pull up the
channel and go through it that have
gotten tens of millions of views and
they would have gotten 10 plus million
views even on a small channel so people
who say oh well I could be Mr Beast if I
had money well hey I didn't start off
with money I was poor I had no money and
it took me like seven years just to buy
a camera saving up from YouTube and B
some of our most free videos literally
like anyone could do like you know maybe
spend a little bit less on a tent but
still it's not that expensive but back
to the Ryan thing I agree I think what
Ryan did was like remember there used to
be like the Logan Paul's the KC's and
all these vloggers but vlogging died
because it was repetitive boring and to
be honest like there's only so much
interesting stuff you can do in a 24
hour period And if you have to do that
every day it's just like almost
impossible to like make it interesting
so that kind of died off
um and then you kind of have like the
rise of what we have and like spectacles
and and just cool things that people go
oh my gosh that's crazy
um and so he kind of Blended it together
he was the first person I've ever seen
that made what I call Modern vlogging
like he took the old format of vlogging
that people used to love like Casey
would get millions of views of video
Logan would get millions of views video
Jake you know romanat would go down the
list so clearly there's any reason we
like vlogging before it got stale so he
found the way to do vlogging but with an
overarching goal that makes it
interesting so now and then like the
great reset you don't know if next video
he's going to get started back to zero
uh you know he has to literally make the
money to buy the plane ticket to then
make money to live off of and sleep and
so it's also very interesting engaging
so there's like an overarching through
story it's like each video is
interesting you don't know if he's going
to restart if he's going to be able to
feed himself and there's a giant payoff
at the end there's an incentive to keep
watching him coming here and surprising
me so that is what I would call Modern
vlogging and he's the first person to
kind of crack the code the only thing is
I don't know which is why I'm excited to
see his next series in his next one I
don't know how you keep like I'm you
know keep doing that over and over again
a big part of it is very taxing on him
there's a revolving around him and I'm
super curious to see what the next one
is how strategic is it for you to bring
on your friend
oh like Chris Chandler Carl in them yeah
this is Jax Jackie yeah for this or
jackpot that I'd be like oh wow that is
interesting I was just curious because
in the beginning it was mainly just you
and then you know obviously like brought
on Chris and then from there you went to
just basically your own your own friend
group and then from there now you're
just doing a bunch of random people is
there any reason from this like gradual
change from just you into like a group
of people that you know it depends so
you're talking about like the core boys
that are in every video or you're
talking about the contestants uh I feel
like a lot of the time the videos now
they include the contestants or just
like a lot of yes but the thing is the
people the only people that are
consistent in every video are Nolan Carl
Chris Chandler and like so those guys
are there just because we're friends and
because we the share like the hotels
we're about to be flying around the
world for two weeks like we would go
crazy you know
um so it's like the we don't cast and
you know churn through a thousand
different people and blah blah it's
literally just like if Chris went out
and got a new best friend today they'd
probably start popping in the videos
it's just kind of how it works uh
assuming they also get along well with
Carl and Chandler and and uh me so like
it was just me and Chris at the start
and then uh who was and then Chandler
was our janitor and Kristen challenge
just occasionally hung out and like uh
and so then I was like okay well
Chandler's his friends video and the
fans love them and he you know um and he
got along well with us and there you go
now it's me Kristen Chandler and then
Carl was one of our editors and then uh
Chris and him just became Inseparable
that's funny that's how Chris is the
hardest person behind I'm friends for so
if someone hits it off with Chris and
they actually like like hanging out then
I'm like yes we struck gold because it's
pretty easy for everyone else to like
them and so they started becoming
friends and so then we were just like
Chris just didn't want to film unless
Carl was holding the camera and
eventually I was just like okay well we
just put them on camera and it was great
the audience loved him turned out well
and then Nolan's just been a friend of
mine for like five years like as long as
they're friends with everyone I think
that natural camaraderie and just flow
just shows on camera and I think that's
the most important thing because you
can't fake friendship you know what I
mean if that makes sense yeah I know you
spoke a lot about scrapping your videos
you said this on like a lot of different
podcasts and uh I was wondering are
there any recent video ideas that you've
scrapped of what the problem is our
videos are getting so expensive and I I
reinvest so much of the money that I
can't afford scraps like I used it's a
lot easier to scrap a hundred thousand
dollar video than a two to three million
dollars yeah yeah but like the island
video for example we went out there did
like got the hundred contestants down
there terraformed the island went to
film it it was terrible like there's a
lot of bottlenecks like you know
importing stuff to the Bahamas there was
problems there the pier got ripped away
because of waves I didn't like the way
certain parts of the island so we had to
move a couple hundred trees so it looked
better on the beach scene and so we
ended up not filming it but we spent
like two million dollars like doing it
all and then
um yeah then we ended up going back a
month later because we just needed way
more time to terraform the island so
usually now the videos are so big that
if I scrap it we just refund it later
but most of them it sucks because most
of money you don't really recoup so it's
like whatever I'm trying to really get
it down because it's brutal like losing
a million or two million dollars
wow and all the videos that you have
scrapped in the past do you think that
there would be any good reason to post
those on YouTube even if it's on a
different channel so you don't want to
post something yeah I saw that it's like
most view videos unexpected I was
watching his videos like wait what that
is cool yeah because it's like a little
Easter egg that's probably if I scrap a
video in the future I'll probably just
auction it off or like or upload it on
someone else's Channel I mean yeah I can
upload on Mr Beast too and make a little
money but I don't know I feel like it's
funnier to uploaded on Ludwig's Channel
I thought that was hilarious yeah I
enjoyed it I watched I mean I lost a
million dollars but hey at least we got
a funny joke oh gosh that's cool do you
ever feel imposter syndrome with all of
your success sometimes like maybe you
weren't deserving of it or anything uh
imposter syndrome so I think I did at
one point like it's still if I walk into
Walmart like 30 people follow me around
I'm like oh I feel or you the weird when
I feel that actually the only time I
really feel is like when we get to make
a wish because now that we're really
starting to get big we get those quite a
bit and I I'm like all the people on the
planet like why me you know what I mean
and so I I tell them like don't give
them give them their wish back like I'll
send them a video saying hi and you know
talking to them or whatever but don't
waste their [ __ ] wish on me that
makes me feel horrible
um so I guess in that sense I kind of
feel it I want to get your advice from
me I feel like I've kind of tapped out
in terms of what I could do on YouTube I
know there's something bigger I don't
know what it is yet but YouTube is going
so well with everything that I don't
want to stop what I'm currently doing
yep but I don't feel the same passion as
I did three years ago okay it's going so
well so when you look at the numbers
everything is the the best it's it's
been but I feel like there's something
else I don't know what that is and I'm
having trouble finding them so Your
Flames going out a little bit it is but
I want to continue with the same path
that I have well I mean the answer is
you just got to take risks like whatever
it is that yeah take calculated risks
that you're confident in just like you
know for me like the analogy I said
before when we did all those twitch
donation videos I was getting tons of
views but I just knew like this will get
stale I'm gonna jump ship before it gets
stale and I'm just gonna do the next
best thing I mean you just you have to
be a little bit of a Visionary and
figure out what's the next evolution of
it I think you should do something where
like I think we talked about this like a
year ago you should um like get a
hundred thousand dollars from me and
then like invest it and then we do a
video together in a year to see if you
made me money or not that would be
interesting or uh you know maybe you get
a bunch of other Financial channels
together and you each like take 100
Grand you all invest it and then you
lock it and then you see who made the
most in a year and you'll all get
together that would be like a Next Level
Super Bowl type collab you know what I
mean if you and the five other biggest
Financial channels did that it was like
a competition and whoever made the most
got all the money like that that's the
kind of stuff that you would probably
enjoy your audience would love you'd get
tons of people talking cross promotion
every way it's probably a win could you
imagine if you did that I'm worried that
the audience really cares about
up-to-date news and like quick stuff
that they wouldn't have the attention
span to want I think you're crazy I
think you've got you and the four other
biggest or maybe three other biggest
Financial YouTubers you each made a
video on your channels you're like okay
you have the cash we're just taking 100
Grand we're gonna we can invest in
whatever we want and then we're gonna
get the uh we're gonna whoever
investment is worth the most in a year
gets the all the money from everyone and
then you each made videos on it and you
made a public website where people could
track the portfolios of all four of you
and then in a year you all make
follow-up videos about your for those
and who won bro tell me that's not good
it's not good I also told them to do in
real life Monopoly with the other
Finance craze he didn't want to do that
either real life Monopoly I don't know
if that will hit but I think because
it's slow well it's just like it's a
little childish and that I could see
like is like 50 years
I invested 100 Grand with a stock
picking monkey who picked stocks
randomly it was my worst performing
video let me see this thumbnail
I don't know we spent a lot of time on
this thumbnail
type in Grown stuff in stock picking
monkey you're probably gonna hate it
picking monkey monkey I'm worried we
spent so long on this thumbnail and it
bombed and by the way on that I changed
the title thumbnail multiple times and
everything I did failed everything yeah
I mean I think um I spent a hundred
thousand dollars on a stock picking
monkey
that just doesn't even make sense right
like if I say I built the world's
largest firework you can or I launched
the whole George fire you can Envision
that I don't even like I spend a hundred
thousand dollars on a stock what is a
stock picking monkey it's not clear it's
we yeah we need we don't get it either
it didn't even make sense how would you
do that I mean I would title it instead
like I would have done it but it starts
with the idea you just [ __ ] yourself
you just picked an idea that's hard to
convey in a title and thumbnail correct
I would have done something like I'm I
blindfolded myself and picked uh I
invested a million dollars into random
companies or something like blindfolding
myself and picking Investments with
darts right or something like that you
know what I mean I would have to think
on it for a couple weeks but I could
come up with something but if you could
convey to the viewer that you
blindfolded yourself and threw Dart set
Investments and you put a million
dollars in those Investments yeah they
would click I'll tell you my idea that I
really want to do at some point it's
what we did today I think that's the
next thing I I don't know if I want this
include because I know everyone would
copy interviewing other creators but
this uh what I did with pokemane strad
man Michael Reeves yeah Kevin O'Leary
all of those videos got at least a
million views yep and people loved them
and did you see the studio tour I did
with Mr who's the boss I did yeah yeah I
think the demand for that kind of
content is crazy yeah
truth be told I told Khan and Samira the
same thing what we're doing here is what
I'm telling Colin and Samara they should
be doing with all other creators so I
would agree like it's a no-brainer it's
basically the top hundred creators like
no one really interviews them I think
that or just business people like Kevin
O'Leary was so interesting in terms of
how he invests and like stuff like that
but like a 15 minute Andrew Tate where
you just asked him when he invested oh
my gosh I've been telling them he
doesn't want to happen I think he will
offer to come on the podcast but Graham
didn't want to read it we have to go to
Croatia I thought it was too risky and I
didn't want him to say something that a
brand might not like just cut it but
then where's where's the the that's I
feel like what's what's
on there and you were like Andrew how do
you make your money and you just let him
talk that would have Pops
I know but I'm worried that that I'm
giving him a platform while he says
something that might reflect yeah from
Andrew Tate yeah pick anyone like LeBron
if you could get a LeBron in a room Shaq
and you're just like how do you make
money what are your investors Banger
like those what is it GQ or whatever
yeah my first million yeah do that but
just do their investment portfolios huge
series you already know the answer yes
I'm
yeah 100 all right thank you guys for
coming out to the iced coffee don't
forget to
subscribe and like subscribe and why
like likes are relevant uh
again tweet Adam and tell him to stop no
thanks for watching I gotta like the
video
cool thanks man no problem